je vous présente le pied de caméra
d'aujourd'hui puisque j'ai oublié le
mien et paraît que c'est comme
d'habitude
non non ça lui aujourd'hui je suis avec
frédéric alias le mythologue la
mythologie non c'est le mythe de l'homme
non c'est le seul mensonge et donc on
traite du mensonge dans sa généralité de
la détection à la compréhension des
mécanismes derrière chaque comme vous
êtes pertinent vous avez compris que
c'était une chaîne youtube dans par les
chaînes youtube
je vous la met dans la description en et
reviendra à la fin alors déjà merci de
venir ici dans les bureaux c'est pas le
sais pas mais mon décor habituel de la
maison parce que je travaille des fois
si sexy veut croire aux gens qui
travaillent et ça que ça s'est passé à
la galante faux décor collecte vient de
bruxelles en plus absolument
seulement je suis belge du coup je
risque de dire 70 au lieu de 70 c'est 90
au lieu de 90 alors pourquoi tu es là
parce que ça vient de la vidéo à la base
sur trump où on allait discuter avec
plein de personnes dont toi sur des
choses qui n'allaient potentiellement
pas dans la manière de devoir en fait
l'information c'est pas la vidéo sur
l'inde
ah oui mais c'était pour le discours de
tracer science exacte enfin lors de
l'élection de donald trump
enfin l'élection ont 60 ans et est donc
suite à ça j'avais proposé de faire une
vidéo est fait a répondu présent et j'en
suis ravi mais moins de même on va pas
se taper dessus je suis désolé par
contre pour ceux qui s'attendent à ça
c'est surtout une belle occasion pour
pourra discuter d'une mais de deux
manières de trouver les sources de gary
thater peut-être sur le web
2 comment toi tu vois les choses par
rapport à ta chaine quai sur le mensonge
au coton te dire que ça m'intéresserait
un des premiers à ma bonne et avoir mis
un petit commentaire c'est vrai que
c'est le premier rang avec bravo
d'ailleurs sur la chaîne tout à fait
j'ai commencé par dire deux choses la
première je suis pas venu pour tabler
sur fabien je suis pas venu pour vous
les dézingués vous le voulez vous le but
et au final la vidéo et la deuxième
chose c'est que ce que je vais dire ne
représente pas une vérité ça représente
ce que je pense
d'un point de vue scientifique comme ça
on est tous d'accord peuvent hériter
ouais c'est ça c'est mes certitudes on
va dire c'est plutôt mes certitudes
donc mon point de vue c'est que
je suis linguiste fut doctorants
psychodrame à vie tourne autour de la
science en général et l'idée c'est que
pour moi il n'y a pas de grandes vérités
il n'y a que des choses qu'on peut
appréhender ci et là alors il y a une
méthode pour les appréhender
si on ne se base que sur l'observation
pour moi on risque d'être victime de
billets c'est à dire des petits
raccourcis qui font qu'on va se tromper
par contre si je peux me permettre par
au mobilier d'aller aussi vers ce qu'on
cherche absolument absolument tout à
fait tout à fait c'est le biais de
confirmation d'hypothèses non mais c'est
il ya plein de petites choses et si on
se base sur nos observations
l'exemple le plus classique c'est de
dire que tous les signes sont blancs
alors qu en fait pas du tout il ya des
signes noirs mais tant qu'on a pas eu de
signes et noir on peut pas le savoir
je mets ton bref de manière plus concise
mon point de vue c'est que il faut qu'on
couple ces observations avec
l'expérimentation et ça ça se fait dans
des labos et le but c'est trouver le
juste milieu en fait entre ce qu'on
trouve dans la nature
est ce qu'on trouve dans nos petits la
boucherie j'avais fait une analyse du
discours de françois hollande
et ce qui était reproché l'homme manière
globale pas certaines personnes
s'étaient de m'appuyer sur rien de
concret de ne pas sourcée en fait la
manière dont dont je faisais les choses
et c'est assez rigolo parce qu'on peut
élargir sa a plus grands en fait en
discuter un tout petit peu avant de
faire la vidéo avec frédéric et je dis
moi quand j'ai lancé cette chaîne je me
suis jamais classé en tant que
vulgarisateur de litière je veux dire ce
que je connais je vais parler de ce que
je sais de ce que j'aime et de ce que je
fais sur scène et hors scène mais à
aucun moment je me suis dit que vous
alliez appréhender sa aussi parfois
comme une vérité voire une vérité
absolue
ce qui n'est pas le cas en fait et c'est
assez intéressant en fait de pouvoir
aussi aujourd'hui se dire quand on
m'amène des choses et des réflexions
différentes
ça me vexe pas au contraire non non
c'est pour cela d'ailleurs c'est alors
et l'excès serait jamais venu c'est ça
c'est ça
associé avec les vulgarisateurs qui ne
font que ça c'est à dire que vont avoir
le temps de potasser le sujet de lire
tout ce qui lie à ce sujet là des
contradictions des confirmations et puis
de vous donner ce que je t'ai rabelais
avait la substantifique moelle ce qui
est très jolie pour dire un condensé de
tout et vous donner l'information telle
qu'elle l'est de manière factuelle et
dans le consensus aussi qu'on en a ça
c'est les traits et d'image ou tousser
en a perdu deux cents à venir madut
servant de la ve république vit mal ou
ai dit si tu nous regardes à mes jeux
vidéos avec leur iphone à un long
métrage du coup parce que en une phrase
mais voilà c'était important de dire ça
et comme j'ai pas ce temps là et cette
exigence là pour avoir ce temps là dans
ce rythme quel mental blog je pars que
sur ce que je connais sur ce quoi je me
suis fait formé à tort ou à raison
toutes les formations sont pas ne venons
pas office de vérité non plus nous avons
pour héros rien et est également de ce
que je pratique donc deux moins
d'expérience personnelle mais c'est pas
une vérité est allé critiquable et je
devrai aujourd'hui à l'état actuel des
choses peut être sûr c'est un peu plus à
l'est recherche un peu plus ce sera
sûrement le cas d'ailleurs les
prochaines mais tu remarqueras qu'il ya
une évolution de la chaîne qui tend vers
ça absolument absolument on en discute
et d'ailleurs on a remarqué que au fur
et à mesure des vidéos il y avait en
fait des vidéos précision comme on peut
les appeler c'est à dire qu'il ya eu par
exemple une vidéo sur non verbale et
puis il ya eu l'importance de te prendre
en compte la baseline un seuil de
référence qui permet de juger des micro
expressions faciales par exemple donc
oui il ya une évolution et
aussi comme tu le disais faire une vidéo
par jour on n'a pas le temps de lire
tout ce qu'on peut lire sur le sujet et
c'est pour ça que c'est aussi notre
tâche en tant que vulgarisateur de
pouvoir venir et vous donner un autre
point de vue en fait vous donner un
un point de vue qui est différent mais
qui n'a pas office de vérité par rapport
à celui de fabien et vice versa je
trouve ce que tu amènes là en fait c'est
le conseil que ce soit moi ou quelqu'un
d'autre ou une formation ou un article
que vous lisez gardez votre esprit
critique ouvert et ne prenez jamais rien
pour argent comptant
n'hésitez pas à faire vos recherches par
vous même et à réfléchir aussi à
linverse en fait peut-être tu veux
synthétiser cette pensée là bas mais en
fait c'est alors c'est très complexe
aujourd'hui d'avoir un esprit critique
parce que on est bombardé d'infos toute
la journée les réseaux sociaux nous nous
inondent d'infos et n'a pas le temps
entre entre ce que je veux vous dire
aussi c'est que il y a des gens qui se
spécialise dans le domaine et qui sont
tout à fait accessible voilà vous nous
envoyez un email normalement dans les
deux jours on vous répond vous dit voilà
c'est un faux et fiable cette info n'est
pas fiable
c'est un faux est à vérifier ses
n'hésitez pas à prendre contact en fait
c c'est important aussi pour nous aussi
en difficulté mais on sait il ya
plusieurs vulgarisateur je sais pas si
je peux citer les noms bah oui mais
voilà on a
on a la tronche-en-biais qui s'occupe de
tout ce qui est bio psychologiquement
peuvent on a signification qui travaille
sur tout ce qui est communication et
communication non verbale plus
spécifiquement et puis on a toute une
équipe d'hommes de scientifiques et plus
spécifiquement de doctorants qui
travaille sur tout ce qui est mensonge
tout ce qui est information en rapport
avec les méthodes de détection de faux
souvenirs tout ce qui est interrogatoire
de police
donc on est plusieurs à pouvoir vous
répondre à ce sujet et si ce n'est pas
notre spécialité on peut vous renvoyer
vers quelqu'un d'autre parce que oui on
a du réseau
attention ils sont partout en fait c'est
ça qui était intéressant c'était de
parfois dans les commentaires on peut
penser qu'il ya des attaques et des fois
c'est même des abonnés qui disent ah
qu'est-ce que vous faites des to et moi
je fais c'est de calmer le jeu
c'est alors parfois c'est des attaques
mais c'est parce que là il faut de tout
pour faire un monde
mais en général c'est plutôt
bienveillant et sait où pour votre bien
on pour voir où moi j'en suis moi et ni
les uns ni des autres sommes en guerre
mais on le sait à partir de mots on peut
en discuter ensemble un pionnier schalit
manquer ce qui n'était pas forcément
fait avant puisqu'on se répondaient que
par commentaire et c'était important
pour moi de proposer plein de fois de
faire une vidéo et je suis content que
tu viennes parce que là je trouve qu'il
ya un poids aussi bien dans ce que je
dis que ça me permet de travailler des
choses que dans ce que tu dis parce que
ça permet de comprendre des choses est
une forme de vigilance dans la et en ça
c'est cool
voilà je suis content d'être là moi
aussi alors on rappelle pour pour la
chaîne de frédéric la chaîne c'est le
mythologue celle que tu as lancé il ya
quelques mois semaines - quelques alors
au moment où on fait cette vidéo ça fait
et à peu près un mois un peu plus et
attention on a cassé l'internet
on est à 2 185 abonnés champagne dont
moi dont lui dont fabien me sentais le
premier vous fonctionne pas et donc
peut-être le deuxième ben je crois pas
que j'appelle promis le demi tout de
suite un à benoît s'est abonné et bravo
champagne et tous et moi j'ai vu fabien
tu es fiat
j'arrête je fais une vidéo j'arrête ma
volonté c'est vraiment de faire un
contenu qui est représentatif de ce
qu'ils y dans la littérature
scientifique
mais en attendant moi il faut que je le
mette à la disponibilité tout le monde
et que je leur rende accessible en
mettant une touche d'humour en plus et
c'est l'humour belge
vous voyez le complexe que ça fait en
fait donc il faut à peu près deux
semaines pour l'instant et comme j'ai
dit je monte enfin je fais tout moi-même
bah voilà ça prend un peu de temps donc
une vidéo toutes les deux semaines sur
le chef de prêts directs
allez découvrir ça je vous recommande et
c'est le lien aussi que je vais vous
mettre la première vidéo sur la
définition du mensonge parce que ça
c'est intéressant avant de vouloir
parler de quelque chose de le définir
donc je vous la recommande vraiment les
vidéos sont fun ça bravo parce qu'il ya
la vraie recherche en écriture et elle
se regarde ça passe crème c'est super
cool merci à vous d'avoir regardé la
vidéo j'espère que ça vous a plu si ça
vous a plu pensez à vous abonner aussi à
ma chaîne si ce n'est pas déjà fait à
celle de notre ami frédéric et le mode
album c'est une vidéo par jour pendant
un an du 1er janvier au 31 décembre donc
rendez vous demain oui mesdames tous les
jours à 17 heures ciao
voilà
[Musique]